it may sound odd or impolite to suggest
that most of us when we are in the grip
of mental illness are no longer capable
of thinking
that's not how it feels of course
from the inside our minds have probably
never felt so busy and so focused from
the moment we wake up in panic and
self-disgust we are ruminating pondering
exploring catastrophic scenarios
scanning our past attacking ourselves
for things we have done and not done
questioning our legitimacy talking to
ourselves about how repulsive we are
paying attention to strange voices
recommending that we are evil and sick
and headed for the worst
and wondering how and whether we should
kill ourselves
our minds don't give us a moment of
respite we may rub our temples to cool
them down and when eventually we fall
asleep we are exhausted by the marathons
our thoughts have run inside us
nevertheless
we may still want to insist for the
kindest and most redemptive of reasons
that we have not been thinking at all
that none of this hive of activity
deserves the title of thinking
it is just illness
to be mentally ill is to be swamped by
secretions of fear self-hatred and
despair that like surging sea water
through a pumping station control desk
knock out all our higher faculties all
our normal ability to sensibly
distinguish one thing from another to
find perspective to weigh arguments
judiciously to see the wood for the
trees to correctly assess danger to plan
realistically for the future to
determine risks and opportunities and
most importantly to be kind and generous
to ourselves
none of these faculties function any
longer but and this is the true
nastiness of the illness we are never
and nowhere alerted to our loss
we are both very ill and very unaware
it looks as though we are continuing to
think as we have always done with all
the usual intelligence and reliability
but that we just have a lot more to
worry about
nowhere along the way does our mind
generously tell us that it has begun to
look at reality through a distorted lens
that it has at some point in the day to
all effects stopped working
no bell goes off no hazard lights start
to flash the mind merely insists that it
is giving us all the normal readings and
that we have objectively entered hell
yet the truth is that we have lost
command of about a third of our minds
and are pulling together our ideas from
the most degenerate traumatized
unreliable and vicious aspects of
ourselves
it's as if a group of terrorists had
donned white coats and were
impersonating prestigious scientists in
order to lay out a set of vicious
theories and prognoses
once we have been through a few cycles
of distorted thinking and recovered
contact with reality
we should do ourselves the kindness of
accepting that on an intermittent basis
we will lose command of our higher
faculties and that there is nothing
embarrassing in recognizing the
possibility and accommodating ourselves
to it very carefully
this is the nature of an illness around
which we will need to take the greatest
care we should start to get better at
detecting when illness might be drawing
in on us what the triggers for it might
be
then when it is upon us we should do and
decide nothing
we shouldn't start to send emails
deliver judgment on our lives or plan
for the future
we should as much as possible stop all
mental activity and rest
we might listen to music have a long
bath watch something untaxing on
television and perhaps take a calming
pill
we should also try to plug our brain
into that of someone else to benefit
from their greater powers of reason
we should have a trusted friend or
therapist whom we can call on at such
moments and ask them if they might
recalibrate and regulate our thoughts
with an injection of their wisdom and
insight
we should willingly put them in charge
of determining how things are for us
they should be allowed to tell us what
we are worth
what we have done what there is to worry
about
and we should do our best to discount
the contrary doom laden signals that
come from inside us
we may have grown up with the idea that
so long as we are conscious our minds
will be working optimally
but mental illness teaches us a more
complicated lesson our higher faculties
those that give us access to reality
are extremely vulnerable and perilously
prone to shut down under the sway of our
emotional complexities
and to do so without telling us
we should strive to become thinkers who
recognize when they are no longer able
to think
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you